les automobilistes devront s'armer de
patience la seconde phase de travaux
commencent pour le chantier de la rd 30
une annonce faite mardi soir à plaisir
par la mairie et le conseil
départemental auprès du public
partir au delà du mois de juin jusqu'à à
peu près le mois d'octobre à y avoir pas
mal de transformation au niveau de la
circulation surtout au niveau du plateau
et des gâtines une phase plus impactants
pour les usagers de la rd 30
la mise en service du giratoire des
gâtines va rendre trois voies de nouveau
accessible les automobilistes pourront
donc emprunter une voirie provisoire
entre ce dernier et la rue pierre curie
ils pourront également circuler dans les
deux sens entre le rond-point et la rue
monnot mais pour avancer les travaux
l'accès du rond-point du pressoir va
être supprimé plus d'accès à la
connexion entre la rd 58 et la rue curie
depuis elle en cours
même situation pour la connexion rue
monnot et la rd58 cette seconde étape
devrait débuter rapidement malgré les
intempéries qui ont eu des conséquences
sur le chantier sa secte et je dirais
pendant quelques jours mais on peut pas
dire que véritablement c'est apporter un
grand retard par rapport aux chantiers
c'est un chantier qui va durer
pratiquement deux ans et demi donc je
dirais qu effectivement c'était assez
sévère mais mais je pense pas que ça
porte je dirais préjudice énormément au
chantier sur la durée en tout cas
l'aménagement et l'élargissement de
l'air d'être en tête un projet majeur
pour le département une opération à 78
53 millions d'euros qu'il a financé à
58% vous relier des bassins de vie qui
sont celui de poissy celui de plaisir et
l'encours avec la ville nouvelle et la
n12 ce sont vraiment des axes
structurants avec un niveau de
circulation qui ne fait que croître
d'année en année et au bout d'un moment
il y avait je dirais d
les axes de circulation qui devenait
emboliser et à partir de là il fallait
quand même apporté une fluidité
le nouveau carrefour de la rue jules
renier devraient également être mises en
service cet été
la fin de l'ensemble des travaux de
voirie est prévue pour l'été 2010 est